you're looking to spice up your cooking
in the new year a warning from consumer
reports heather mills explains how some
spices may contain concerning levels of
dangerous toxins
here's the reason a lot of spices are
grown overseas where contaminated water
can lead to heavy metals in the soil
most of us shake spices on our food and
add them to our recipes without much
thought but consumer reports found there
could be problems inside of all the
spices that we investigated one third of
them had
concerning levels of heavy metals lead
cadmium or arsenic
chief scientific officer james dickerson
says consumer reports tested 126 herbs
and spices from 38 different companies
in every brand of oregano and time
concerning levels of heavy metals were
detected the metals were also found in
almost all brands of ginger and basil
and in about half of the paprika and
turmeric brands studies have shown that
frequent exposure to lead cadmium and
arsenic can be damaging over time for
children during their early stages of
development
these heavy metals can adversely impact
their neurological development
as well as the respiratory development
the american spice trade association
says their own analysis shows spices
make up less than point one percent of
dietary lead exposure in children ages
one to six and the risk is low in adults
dickerson says the good news is every
tested brand of curry and garlic powder
black pepper coriander sesame seed and
saffron did not have concerning levels
of metals think about what herb spices
that you and your family use and
diversify the amount that you use so
don't overload on a particular spice and
if you're wondering organic products did
not perform any better than non-organic
spices heather mills live local now